foreign
comes from Meredith in Wisconsin I'm 27
years old and trying my best to do the
baby steps so I can buy a house with a
was at with as little debt as possible
but I feel like in today's market it's
nearly impossible to find a decent house
that's affordable how can I accelerate
my savings to buy the house I really
want that's currently outside of my
budget
um this is a tough one Rachel there's a
lot of people especially in their 20s
and 30s frustrated right now with how
the housing market has been the last few
years and with wages not increasing at
that rate they're going this isn't fair
now the average house is 400 grand and
I'm making 30 40 50. how am I ever going
to save up a down payment in order to
get the house that I really want yep
well I think that's the phrase there
it's what I want right and so it's not
always about what you want it's what you
can't afford even if it's not a lot and
and it and it does like it it sucks that
you look back and you're like if in 2019
it was a different world and here we are
in 2022 and it's not that prices have
you know significantly dropped it's
slowed down the market has which is
great for buyers you have a little bit
more room for negotiation and all that
but it's still a lot of places have
still held that value even when it's
spiked up so
um it you know
I I feel like I'm gonna sound cold
George No usually that's yours usually
it's me I'm very happy you're the one to
do this take note America but I'm like
but what sucks is like math doesn't care
heartless match doesn't have emotion and
so we can sit and complain about it
because it does suck like I mean yeah
but if you just sit there and complain
then what else are you gonna do so you
have to be able to say okay here's the
reality here's the reality I'm not gonna
be able to buy in that county that I
wanted to right now I'm gonna have to
you know go 20 minutes further out than
I was expecting to get that kind of
house or I'm gonna have to stay in the
area I want to buy in but my house is
going to be significantly smaller than
what I was expecting and so again that's
not fun none of you want it you want
what you want
but when the numbers aren't there you
have to deal with okay where are the
numbers playing out for me if I really
want to buy a home and I mean it's not
fun but that's the truth that's what you
have to do because it's not going to be
a great thing you know being a homeowner
it's wonderful we want everyone
eventually too because it's a really
smart place to put your money
financially but it also is so
emotionally driven sometimes for people
that they jump in without you know doing
the due diligence of having a secure
Foundation of not having payments not
having debt having an emergency fund
being wise as they get into it making
sure again even what they're buying
isn't out of their budget and uh it's
it's hard but it's what you got to do
now oh yeah it makes me think of that
old adage
cheap fast for good you can only choose
two
you know if you want it cheap and fast
we can do that but it won't be good
you know and so there's a level that you
have to compromise sliding scales when
it comes to housing of all right I
really want that house either it's going
to take more time yeah to get the house
that I want or I can do it faster but
I'm gonna have to go 30 minutes into the
next County and it might be a condo
instead of the single family home right
and it might need a few upgrades that I
have to make a few years from now
because it doesn't have the kitchen that
I wanted with the backsplash and so we
talked about this on Smart money happy
hour in our first episode about how HGTV
ruined our generation
they ruined our lives because the
expectations are great houses could look
like yeah and now we're like everyone
hated their house after watching chip
and Joe make a house beautiful like I
want to do that and so there's a level
of patience that we need resetting
expectations and on top of that she's
asking how do I accelerate my savings
and me and my wife we did this one
buying our first home which the
Nashville area is super expensive we
live in one of the wealthiest counties
in the nation here in Williamson County
Tennessee and we decided all right we're
gonna get a town home for our first home
we don't need a giant single family home
for Just the Two of Us yep and so we did
that we increased our income I was
taking on side jobs I was building
websites I was hosting outside events I
was doing all kinds of things just to
bring in extra income to save up for
that down payment we did no spend months
we cut a lot of luxuries and
subscriptions and things that we would
have loved to do as a newlywed couple
but we went you know what the house is a
priority over that vacation
and those are the kinds of things you
have to really grapple with in order to
have the things you want yep for sure
you know I took Winston and I close to a
decade almost 10 years to get to the
point that we're like okay we're going
to upgrade to the next home and it was a
long goal it was a long goal that we
knew and even toward the end we weren't
quite where we wanted so yeah we were we
were cutting stuff I was yeah I was
taking on any kind of speaking thing I
could yeah I was like I was saying yes
to everything there's a kind of gazelle
intensity to it of that yes toward the
end which was which was great because we
we needed it and that's what we wanted
that was our goal but here's the thing
too George is it's not worth having a
home it feel you know for someone that's
looking
mostly for your first time home buyers
again we want you to get to that place
where you can own a home because it's
it's just smart financially
but that it looks So Glamorous from the
outside and when people make a move a
bad financial move into something they
can't afford I would say the mental
health the stress the anxiety
it offsets what you thought this house
was going to be and how great it was
it's like oh my gosh I would rather go
back to where we were and rent and not
have the stress that we have now and so
there's there's a give and take there
when you go and you move into something
you can't afford it's it's not it
doesn't create a glamorous experience
here's the big takeaway you can tweet
this Rachel thank you home ownership is
not the antidote to your lack of
happiness
it's not wow it's not going to be there
because home ownership has a lot of
costs and on top of that those people
that do it prematurely they're also in
debt in other areas so now you have the
car payment you have the student loans
you have the credit cards you have your
buyers and then let me say this on the
on the emotional contentment side George
you take you with you into the new house
too
Rachel is ice cold today and we love to
see and there's something about it
because I went through this too where I
was like I just want a different kitchen
I would be if life would just be better
if we had a bigger kitchen you know I
had all these thoughts now life would be
better if you went to therapy and got
control of your marriage how about that
and so then I look and I'm like oh my
gosh but like you're a lot it's still
you moving in even if it's a bigger
kitchen it's still all that
discontentment that you have another in
other parts of your life too so it's
it's not the end I'll be all right so
there's a hilarious Tick Tock out there
that I think sums up the frustration
that America's feeling do you want to
see it I would love to see it okay let's
roll that
how is any young person ever gonna own a
home it's maybe Hate Old People I see a
few of you in here tonight I hate you
because every old person in a city like
LA or New York or London is the same
they're like my house is worth two
million dollars but when I bought it in
1981 I paid 11 raspberries for it
every Young Person's like I have done
roommates
we each pay eleven thousand dollars a
month
every single one of us is a lawyer
except for Ted and every single own
person's like I'm a librarian with a
home at the beach oh my goodness
that while it's an exaggeration that is
hilarious to that yes well a lot of the
pressures coming from parents who by the
way raise their kids to go follow your
passions at all costs and go 300 000
into the student loan debt and then
they're like why are you married why
don't you have a house yet where are the
grandkids give us and they're like dude
I can't even breathe I can't get to next
week let alone buy a house and so this
doesn't just fall this is not to blame a
generation this is to go listen we've
made some mistakes we have to accept
responsibility and we have to accept the
reality that home prices are insane now
what are we gonna do that's right what's
next and having options that's another
thing you know and you can add School
College on top of this the tuition how
insane it's gotten I mean all of it so
all this stuff has and so what it does
it forces you to look and say okay
what what is the wisest route because
it's not just like oh you have to own a
home tomorrow or you have to go get a
college degree right like it's not the
it's not that black and white anymore
it's like okay what what can I afford in
this moment where do I want to be in
five years right and so working towards
something as well yes but it is and it
starts it's hard guess what I have to
get out of debt first and have an
emergency fund and then save up the down
payment and yes that might be three four
five six years from now but when you get
there you're gonna have a piece about it
you did it with intentionality
no regrets right Rachel
George it'll never die God bless you God
bless you my friend